yo this is cool
elon musk finally responds to project
veritas sting in which twitter engineer
says all workers there are kami as f
and that they hate the billionaire tesla
boss he said is this legit
that's it
that's what he said but those three
words mean so much oh yeah in the viral
uh the viral video
so
actually i think they're so i post this
video it's got like six million bits of
veritas video i posted it because it was
newsworthy ends up people are blowing it
up and putting it like crazy and i'm
like all right cool um this guy says he
only works four hours a week i think i
think he basically says people can and
like he did i don't want to say that he
always does i don't know exactly what
he's trying to intend uh um but he also
talks about how the company is just left
left left left left how they all hate
elon he talks about how the right will
tolerate the left-wing speech but the
left will say if you don't ban them we
quit so twitter basically says okay ban
the people on the right because the
people on the right don't care all of
that being confirmed but in those three
words is this legit elon musk who is
currently he's currently frozen the deal
he's delaying it saying prove your bots
and now everyone's saying oh he's trying
to shake him down or he's trying to get
out of the deal
i still think elon musk knows what he's
doing i still think he has a good
likelihood to win i think he i think
he's likely exposed fraud and with this
veritas video elon musk may now be able
to actually renegotiate the deal that's
the big news because a lot of people on
the left are saying elon musk uh for for
uh was willing to forego due diligence
saying we'll do the deal as is
the contract is the contract he's right
the apparently the twitter board is
saying no he's got to buy it with this
video release though elon musk can be
like whoa whoa wait a minute you didn't
disclose the work hours
you didn't disclose
censorship or political ideology but
more so i think the work hours in this
is going to give him an ability to try
and go back at the twitter board
the real victim is the woman on the date
who had to hear all of this on a first
date
that is a lot for a kindergarten i
believe women and i got to tell you
project veritas journalist right
there's a meme
where it says if you are an engineer at
twitter
and a beautiful young woman
wants to know about your job it's james
o'keefe
do not say anything
i think that's the easiest way to put it
it's so funny that there's no
edward snowden-esque leaker and
literally all you need to do is go put a
hot chick in front of a tech nerd and
it's over you've just blown the company
this is this is why
so i'm watching this leak the other day
and i feel bad for this guy yeah i mean
he doesn't seem like a bad dude he says
that he's okay with elon buying the
company you know he's become more left
but he's you know he he doesn't seem
like a bad guy he's telling people like
this is what's happening at the club
well he's saying it's bad for business
he doesn't even sound like he's being
ideological he's like this is hurting
the place i work but the sad thing is
you know he meets this this young
attractive woman on tinder and he thinks
maybe he's finally found love
but it was james o'keefe the whole time
i you know we should do we should do a
skit where we get a guy talking to a
beautiful young woman and then he's like
wait a minute something's off and then
he grabs her hair and he pulls it off
james
like actually james it's actually james
they pulled the wig down and then james
he's sitting there in a suit he's got a
microphone tell me more about what is
there in the pimp suit
i've been having nightmares about that
forever i love it
this is the sting operation it's it's
young women on tinder and it works i
mean it's genius it's brilliant it's
really so basic i think it's legit i
think it's legit
well i think it's because like man when
it comes to this stuff especially this
culture where like no one is encouraged
to cultivate any self-control when it
comes to sexuality i think a lot of
young men are like okay this like could
be a sting like there's a probability
but i'm just gonna try anyway yeah
that's why no one uh nowadays wears
condoms anymore it's just the
whistleblower equivalent of that
i wonder if
we are being arrogant and maybe this
dude what's his name uh cyril
he might be he might be swimming in
women you know what i mean he might he
might just be kicking back with his own
pimp outfit and he's like just another
girl at seven o'clock make it quick lady
like i mean he only works four hours a
week right he's got a lot of time on his
head maybe he does just have a bunch of
different girlfriends we don't know that
i gotta give him i thought he was
playing her yeah maybe he's spying on
her for another organization like we
don't know maybe he's wearing it he's
trying to take down o'keefe it's just
like a circular reign of hell can you
imagine how paranoid james o'keefe must
be on a date he's like yeah he's like
eventually this is coming i know it does
work yeah he's just always trying to
shake them down for microphones
so uh he's like let's go to the beach
for our date yeah well you know we'll go
swimming yeah we'll go slower yeah
i gotta admit i do feel bad for for a
lot of these people that get get that
get caught by uh o'keefe because i don't
think
not every single person that gets
exposed is a bad guy right this guy is
just he's a senior engineer he's in this
environment
he probably doesn't know or care about
what's going on culturally he does a
little bit and he's like yeah this is
what's happening
and so now
he's forced to be a whistleblower
basically like but
i i still respect and think what james
is doing is completely legitimate i mean
it's real reporting and if we can't hear
what these people are saying and doing
and we don't know what's going on these
companies bad things happen right so
this guy getting you know basically
admitting everything and he he's
different from a lot of what we've seen
when we've seen like that google woman
and she's talking about stuff it's like
you've got people at big tech companies
talking about how they set policy how
they do policy this is a guy in a date
who's like yo is what my company is like
isn't that crazy right so now he's
deleted his twitter account i think he's
deleted his linkedin the uh twitter has
issued a statement to their tweeps
that's what they think that's what they
call it uh that's the most offensive
print yeah i'm super offended
so what is a tweet is that a customer is
that someone who works there someone who
works there so here's the thing he
didn't mention that on the day yeah no
wonder funny he's still too ashamed of
that he's like they call us tweets yeah
they've been funny if he just started
crying he was like they call us tweets
all right so uh we have this uh the
instagram post from veritas targeting of
tweeps says the email tweeps
can't believe i'm reading that
as we expected a video was posted this
evening by project veritas depicting a
tweep
allegedly speaking about a number of
company issues we're in contact with the
person involved in doing everything we
can to help them there may be more
videos to come and we're continuing to
monitor the situation help them help him
you mean why are they saying them them
are we learning something about serum
yeah but all right is it not a little
bit interesting that everyone at twitter
who didn't like elon musk felt very
comfortable voicing their displeasure
with him potentially taking over the
company even though he may have been
running the place
in the near future but someone who has
issues with the way twitter is run now
tries to be very quiet and the only way
we're able to get information from them
is on hidden camera right right right
right it goes on it says please review
my previous note on how you can protect
yourself and your fellow tweeps from
similar attempts in the future if you
think you are being targeted or have
been targeted contact blank at
twitter.com redacted for safety and
privacy of those involved we ask you do
not tweet about the situation or any
related issues please remember that we
all have an obligation to protect
confidential proprietary information and
not discuss internal conversations
policies or products outside of work
take care and stay safe pat pat as soon
as you sent the email out they leaked it
to project veritas so that last message
right there fell on deaf ears for sure
whoopsie oh good though i mean
cyril may not be somebody who's stepping
up and willing to speak out about the
what i view as corruption within the
company somebody is
somebody somebody you know is is showing
what they're saying behind the scenes
and exposing what i would view as
malfeasance also are there any hot
blondes that can go undercover and find
out why i'm shadow band on instagram
there you go can we just start like just
hiring our own hot girls to find out
i'm imagining the same scenario with
like a hot young girl talking to mark
zuckerberg and how he would be no idea
how to respond yeah he would just be
like like staring at her blankly yeah
she's like tell me about your work my
work is good
like start speaking to her in binary
hey buddy what's happening no i don't
know
zuckerberg's married i think right oh
yeah
yeah i do always think it's stupid that
people try and do these arguments where
it's like if for some reason they don't
like you they attack your manhood yeah
but primarily on the left i always find
that funny yeah like why is it that
people on the left who are the ones who
are like traditional masculinity isn't a
thing and then they're like you're an
incel it's like
okay well because one thing the left oh
like because everybody don't believe
well exactly the left doesn't believe
the things that they espouse they know
that conservatives are generally more
sensitive to the idea of whether or not
they're being considered masculine or at
least they assume that they're
constantly trying to like break down
gender barriers but they think oh if i
challenge his manhood then i'll be able
to manipulate him into doing what i want
everyone has the same fears everyone has
the same insecurities everyone's a
hypocrite everyone uses the same stuff
except for this guy yeah
but like it's it's like they go after
ben shapiro first of all
they i i've heard over and over how
short ben shapiro is yeah then we go and
meet him and he's that short normal like
average taller than all of us he was
like six seven it was like he's like
another live from the liberal media
i was like
did he just dunks on all of us like
literally they they actually built an
oversized set because they want to no no
i think he's like a slightly uh about
average yeah and i was like oh he's sick
he's taller than me great there you go
yeah yeah yeah
you didn't you didn't have to tell
people that like
they all know but they're like they lie
about his height
and then they also call him an incel and
ben's just sitting there with his kids
and his wife and he's like i have a
family and then you're like i don't
understand why who are they trying to
hurt
yeah
go after ideas go after ideas that's all
you have to do if you have any merit to
yours go after ideas like any time i was
it's like when you're fighting with your
girlfriend or boyfriend and the second
you realize you're wrong you just like
change the subject and panic you're like
oh you said you were gonna do the last
week and it's just you're panicking
you're doubling down and you're
panicking and you're you're short all
right bud you're out of ideas
yeah no it's true
there are so many it's funny because you
bring up relationships there are so many
different communication habits that you
see predominantly on the left that would
be deeply unhealthy in any kind of
relationship so for example they assume
that they know that you have some kind
of like racist attitude inside of you or
sexist attitude and then they're just
like trying to picket your words in some
way that'll justify their narrative they
like start with the conclusion right
that you're a bad person acting in bad
faith so they can malign that's not how
you have conversations with people
that's not how you have conversations
with people it's deeply unhealthy that's
why i was saying the other day when we
had mad on i was like we don't do uh we
don't do uh stuntmen right political
stuntmen people who do make games of
things and they're like infotainment
stuff
i'm not gonna invite them on i mean
maybe but people who have done it to us
are just like out the first time they do
it yeah so if they if they try and pull
any stunts to rage bait their audience
and go woo look at us we're culture wars
i'm like yeah we're not gonna fight okay
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you